the last episode of Matt and Shane's
secret podcast was unlike any episode
they've ever recorded by now most people
know that Matt Shane and the rest of
their crew are all moving to Austin
Texas but so far Matt mccusker is the
only one who's physically relocated so
while he waits for Shane Gillis to
arrive in a few weeks Matt recorded a
surprise episode with one of the biggest
Advocates of the new Austin Texas comedy
scene Welcome to Austin Texas a lot of
fun times ahead Not only was it wild to
see an episode of Matt and Shane in a
podcast Studio instead of a living room
but Matt and Tony were also a brand new
combination of comedians that we've
never seen together before now that you
guys are here you and Shane on kill Tony
at the same time literally the most
requested guest in the history of the
show it's been the last 2 years you guys
really